faits divers dans le Gard le chef des
majorettes condamné pour viol sur ces
majorettes c'est courageux parce que
dans un village les majorettes se sont
souvent les plus moches
Stéphane Guillon
voilà Stéphanie messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir mon système
voilà voilà municipale on commence par
la violence qui embrasait cette semaine
la cité de Neuilly-sur-Seine deux bandes
se sont affrontées les martinons oui oui
contre les martinons non non un bilan
très lourd de serre-tête arrachées et un
tailleur Chanel déchiré
à ce propos Cécilia aurait-elle reçu le
message suivant si tu ne reviens pas
j'annule Martinon
en tout cas un grand bravo à Jean
Sarkozy qui fête à 22 ans sa première
trahison politique
oui chez lui c'est génétique petit il a
bu son père marié Jacques Martin puis
partir avec la mariée soutenir Chirac
puis voter Balladur
en déplacement officiel Sarkozy fais
gaffe à de plus envoyer de SMS dommage
le texte était tout trouvé ma Carlita
suit entouré de guyanais à poil tout le
monde s'en merde c'est l'horreur lol
Nicolas
match nous apprend que 66% des Français
sont pour que Carla continue à chanter
bah oui forcément le silence se reposant
Brice Hortefeu souffre de sa mauvaise
image en Norvège nous dit-il le ministre
de l'Intégration et le plus populaire la
Norvège un paradis pour Brice Lama les
immigrés les plus basanés sont châtain
clair
[Applaudissements]
les pilotes de l'armée israélienne sous
viagra il serait beaucoup plus résistant
à l'altitude attention quand même à ne
pas se tromper de manche
[Applaudissements]
faits divers dans le Gard le chef des
majorettes condamnés pour viol sur ces
majorettes c'est courageux parce que
dans un village les majorettes se sont
souvent les plus moches
télévision Daniel Bilalian réclame une
minute trente de foot gratuit sur le
service public une minute trente pour
voir les buts du PSG c'est trop et pour
voir ce qu'ils encaissent c'est pas
assez
[Applaudissements]
beau public ce soir
France Télévisions une programmation de
plus en plus dynamique mercredi soir les
personnes âgées avaient le choix entre
les Victoires de la musique classique
sur France 3 et une spéciale Alzheimer
sur France 2
[Musique]
à propos de Michael Jackson M Pokora
déclare il m'a ouvert à la musique on
respire
on respire
Cloclo les hommages se préparent pour
les 30 ans de sa disparition moi je
serais pour qu'on donne son nom à une
centrale électrique
et ouais on termine avec une mauvaise
nouvelle un malheur en arrivant jamais
seul non seulement David Douillet
conserve Bernadette Chirac pour
l'opération Pièces Jaunes il espérait
Carla Bruni mais il récupère
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
une pensée à tous les enfants malades
entre fogiels qui s'habillent en clown
Lorie qui fait la manche et PPDA qui
propose un numéro de trapèze volant
pauvre gosse c'est pas parce que tu es
malade que ta mauvais goût à la semaine
prochaine merci
Stéphane pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innaarditude abonnez-vous et un pouce
bleu